[Musique]
une éternité s'est écoulé depuis les
effroyables événements du mardi des
tacos nos vies ont sombré dans le chaos
cette nouvelle vie nous a tous aguerris
ils ont dû aussi d'un café s'il vous
plaît un noir et un avec un léger
soupçon de l'est et 25
enfin presque tous un effort
et nos menus toujours pas été versée
bonjour les bébés des égouts et met il
faut que tu arrêtes de faire comme si
tout était super génial si pas le cas
oui je sais c'est pour ça que je me suis
forgé un côté hyper dur et insensible
regarde une étoile filante fait un peu
au nord un nouveau truc
qu'est-ce qui fabrique
j'en sais rien mais ce son est super
branché
[Musique]
belga chds
c'est comme s'il savait où on va ouais
c'est dingue et ma mémoire autre chef le
plus redoutable huila c'est le spécial
plus redoutable
en réalité les combats c'était moi mais
donc tu t'es battu et tu as construit et
tu as tout déchirer et c'est le mag
minable qui était le chef il
non
accroche-toi à des feuilles planty on
est parti pour sauver lucie et tous les
autres qui ont été capturés
[Musique]
voyez le système si star du web ne
donnait pas la satisfaction de vous
entendre dire waouh devant ça c'est
encore pire ne des plus rien